[Música]
buenas tardes mi nombre es yaiza rubio y
soy más joven que internet internet
nació en 1969 con el objetivo de
realizar comunicaciones mucho mucho más
rápidas entre diferentes organismos
públicos del gobierno de eeuu vale 1969
fue un gran año porque digo esto porque
nace internet
el hombre llega a la luna
y nace también jennifer aniston
porque me gusta tanto jennifer aniston
bueno pues tiene un motivo porque
siempre tiene las películas un final
feliz
siempre encuentra al príncipe perfecto
el amor ideal bueno pues el pobre
internet no ha tenido ese final feliz
ahora mismo internet bueno los usuarios
de internet sufrimos hackeos problemas
de seguridad brechas de seguridad y
sobre todo tenemos un problema con la
privacidad de nuestros datos pero bueno
aún así con todos esos problemas con los
que nació internet porque como decimos
internet nació con el objetivo de
establecer comunicaciones y no ser
seguro por defecto ni privada ni
teniendo en cuenta la privacidad por
defecto
bueno pues empieza a popularizarse se
populariza a partir de 1989 cuando nace
la web
y bueno esta es la del aspecto de cómo
fue la primera página web que se publicó
en internet
ese día aparece que el diseñador gráfico
estaba de vacaciones
y bueno el broma la verdad que tiene
mucho mérito este trabajo
la página web bueno pues es muy sencilla
no tiene mucha tipografía diferente no
tiene un gran diseño gráfico pero bueno
todos los modelos otras la mayoría de
las empresas a día de hoy no cuestionan
el hecho de no tener una página web
cualquier empresa tiene que tener una
página web porque es como si no
existiera el problema vienen con los
medios de comunicación los medios de
comunicación
bueno pues hace dos décadas llegaron un
momento de decir ok yo quiero poner mi
periódico online pero llegan los
usuarios y dicen oye yo no voy a pagar a
mí dame la información de forma gratuita
no entonces bueno pues ellos intentaron
al principio poner un botoncito es decir
ok lectores suscribiros y pagarme dinero
también
bueno pues llegó eso y parece que no
funcionó en cambio ha evolucionado el
modelo de negocio a internet y ahora
pues los medios de comunicación llevan
bastante tiempo aprovechándose o sea se
benefician
de sus beneficios miren d
de la publicidad pero esa publicidad que
no es general para todos los usuarios es
segmentada
no tenemos publicidad que va
directamente a una persona porque sabe
ese periódico que le gusta
jennifer aniston o le gusta hacer
deporte y que hay detrás de eso pues al
final un modelo de negocio basado en la
privacidad de los datos la privacidad de
los datos personales como por ejemplo lo
que hace google yo soy muy fan de google
y esto no es el objetivo de criticar al
google no sea google invierte mucho
dinero en seguridad para que realmente
sus productos pues sean seguros o lo más
seguros posibles más bien vale porque la
seguridad cien por cien no existe no lo
podemos olvidar pero bueno ellos ofrecen
productos y servicios de forma gratuita
de hecho llegan a tener incluso ocho
productos que tienen más de mil millones
de usuarios cada uno valiosa que aquí
nadie se cuestiona no tener gmail o no
tener acceder al drive y hacer una
presentación o cosas así luego google
invierte muchísimo dinero todos los años
en mejorar sus modelos de operaciones
vale invierten mucho dinero en data
centers con el objetivo de procesar cada
vez más rápido y almacenar muchos más
datos personales y aquí les oye dónde
está la trampa y cómo invierten mucho
dinero y hombres con productos gratuitos
qué pasa cómo ganar dinero no bueno pues
todavía aún así google duplicó los
beneficios el año pasado los duplicamos
los multiplicó por 2 y luego los
beneficios en concreto que venían de
publicidad aumentaron un 20% gracias a
que al perfilado de usuarios y esto
todavía se incrementa es todavía se de
más se refleja mejor el tema de las
redes social
las redes sociales pues empiezan a
partir del año 2002
y ya un poquito más adelante pues ya las
más famosas pero veamos el ejemplo de
utilización de datos personales por
parte de twitter tampoco critico a
twitter twitter también invierte mucho
en seguridad bueno me imaginemos qué
una floristería llega el día de san
valentín y quiere ofrecer flores a sus
usuarios
a los usuarios que tengan twitter vale
bueno pues entonces probablemente esa
floristería
tenga una página web y todos los
usuarios que accedemos a las páginas web
cuando hacemos por primera vez o
llevamos tiempo sin acceder a esa página
web aparece un banner y pone política de
buques cookies y tú dices sí sí acepto
todo todo pero ya pero ya pero ya y doy
toda la información personal del mundo
bueno pues si nos damos un poquito
cuenta si abrimos un poquito ese
desplegable podemos ver ahora están
obligados por gpr poner y notificar
exactamente a qué empresa va a
destinados esos datos personales y qué
dato personal en concreto de acuerdo
vale ya no sólo la página web sino
probablemente esa página web tenga un
boletín de suscripción o si quiere subir
suscribirte a mis últimos modelos de
flores
bueno pues tú dices ok si me interesan
las flores y bueno pues tú hay rellenas
el boletín
y dices vale pero dame tu correo
electrónico o tu número de teléfono vale
como nos registramos en twitter que es
lo que es completamente necesario para
hacer un registro en twitter en la
dirección de correo electrónico o el
número de teléfono por lo tanto ya ahí
tiene twitter ese match de decir ok yo a
estos usuarios les tengo que mostrar la
información de las flores
los aceites de las cookies y a través de
direcciones de correo y el número de
teléfono vale pero también viene el tema
de la personalización basada en tu
identidad inferida madre mía qué
concepto esto viene a partir de que
twitter también quiere saber si solo
solo te conectas a través de twitter for
iphone o twitter for android o tienes un
pc o tienes una tablet nuevo porque al
final tú tienes muchos medios a los que
conectarte a su plataforma y él tiene
que saber que eres tú que tiene que
enseñarte las flores vale bueno pues eso
el para hacer esa inferencia
pues lo que hace es
sabe cuando te conectas desde qué
dirección te conectas y te comunicas con
su página web o cosas de ese estilo
cuándo y cuando te conectas pues ese
estilo ese tipo de variables son las que
él dice ok son la misma persona y luego
también pues twitter tiene determinados
partners se apoyan en partners para
ofrecer también a través de ellos esos
productos y servicios pero también bueno
pues tiene otros partners a los que les
compran bueno determinados
comportamientos les dirá existe en
internet empresas muy grandes y que
realmente son muy rentables que se
dedican a recolectar datos de carácter
personal y entonces twitter by dice ok
quiero informe quiero usuarios que coman
que los por las mañanas pero es que
llegan a hacer hasta este límite hasta
esa precisión sabe twitter de acuerdo
entonces vemos que esto es un problema
un problema porque a veces pensamos que
esto no es justo y no no significa que
no sea legal es completamente legal lo
que están haciendo es un problema de si
realmente esto es justo vale
ahora las empresas esto lo conocen saben
que esto es un problema y ahora toda la
mayoría de las plataformas tienen
páginas web donde tú puedes ver y
controlar tus datos personales pero esto
es otra mentira como la de la donde
aceptó los términos y condiciones quién
se lee los términos y condiciones y las
las opciones de privacidad no sé las de
nadie pero deberíamos hacerlo
y ahora para concluir bueno como hemos
dicho yo soy hacker y como yo hacker que
no sirve el criminal
hay mucha gente hay mucha gente
trabajando en mejorar internet y aquí
más falta dice que se va a la cama y que
cuando el mundo sea justo que le avisen
en algún mundo nosotros no solemos hacer
eso los hackers así que espero que
vosotros tampoco muchas gracias
[Aplausos]